uh the other day i tried to get a dog
i thought i was gonna get a dog first of
all i was gonna get a
spider we were gonna try to get a
tarantula and put a tarantula on the
desk even though
the studio is really good we're gonna
get this guy the goliath
bird eating spider it is the largest
spider in the world
it grows to the size of a dinner plate
um
it is really what it looked like yeah
it's very large and um
i called ben and i said i think we
should drive that to rancho cucamonga
where we found a spider dealer a
tarantula dealer
in an office building in rancho
cucamonga
and i did a science fair project on
spiders when i was a kid i find them
interesting i like that everyone else is
afraid of them they creep me out too
they creep you out because they have the
extra two legs so they walk
you know you know how it is unlike an
insect which is just gross a spider is
terrifying because really
the way it moves nothing really moves
like a spider
so that's what freaks people out um
[Music]
and i was thinking about getting a
spider
like true i mean this is the stage of
quarantine where we're starting to
really
come apart you know you probably notice
it out there in your own life you start
considering things that
you know were inconceivable
just 10 months ago especially in la i
mean things are open and i see people
out other places but in la i mean it's
still really
it's it's shut down but hopefully that's
ending i don't even tell me to go to
austin i got to go to austin
maybe i don't know but
we'll see joe rogan elon musk
first of all i'd go if somebody there
had any money
um we sent elon the tesla rant
that i did yeah i emailed it it's all in
good faith it's all in good fun
it's all in good fun what did he tweet
he said uh something about comedy what
did he say
legalized comments comedy yeah how about
legalize
buying me a house rogan gives lex
friedman his watch lex friedman could
just make his own watch hey why don't
you give me something joe
you've given me a lot it's true but i
mean come on
lex friedman gets a watch from rogan how
cool is that
right on the show rogan turns around and
this is a watch right here look at that
i was on rogan's podcast yesterday and
had on air one of the most special
moments of my life joe took off his very
favorite watch and gifted it to me to
have one of my heroes do that means more
than i can put into words
i'm not worthy but i'll work give me 200
on air in front of everyone give me 200
i don't need your favorite watch give me
200
let me use your airbnb account
i'll pay just let me use your airbnb
account
we'll take care of it so we drive to
rancho cucamonga
to uh the spider room which i re let's
give a shout out to the spider room the
spider room
in rancho cucamonga if you are uh uh
looking for
a spider here it is this guy is the guy
wednesday through friday now we didn't
get a spider here but this guy is the
guy
yeah yeah um it had nothing to do with
him he was great
knowledgeable all of the spiders look
like they're well cared for
um you walk in this office building
and then it's like a regular company
yeah some i don't know what kind of
company it is it looks like an
office where i used to sell mortgages
just like a small
office and then in one of the rooms
there's just 200 venomous spiders
and this guy rents it out
you know your company's doing well when
you have to sublet one of the room one
of your conference rooms not even a
conference room
a small office to 200 venomous animals
but respect so we go there and we um
i go in there and exotic animal people
are odd they just
are i used to go see an anaconda get fed
at dj's reptiles in hicksville
uh long island they're odd the exotic
animal people as you would imagine
they're just different
something is different about you if you
are drawn to snakes and spiders
usually things aren't going great
for the most part if you really get into
venomous animals
[Laughter]
you're not it's not this
very rarely do you walk into a reptile
shop and go
that guy's [ __ ] gorgeous
like that doesn't happen it does that's
just not
the people you it's never like a
a six-pack malibu surfer
perfectly tan body shaggy blonde hair
big titted girlfriend and they're like
do you want to go to the beach today
and then [ __ ] each other senseless or
do you want to go buy a madagascar
hissing cockroaches
and feed it to the spider i'm just
saying
and i'm not you know i was gonna buy a
spider so i'm not
hey so we go in there it just seems like
most of the people
in the trade are
they're like the less successful joe
exotic
you know what i mean like they're not
they're not they don't they don't own a
zoo
right but whatever but it's it seems
like that's not an unfair thing to say
right people that are in there
there's something that you get drawn to
spiders yeah
but god god love of it and i mean
they've got scorpions in there and
they've got brown widows brown widows
are like cousins of black widows and
insanely venomous yeah it's hilarious i
said to the guy go like this they go you
know you wouldn't have like brazilian
wandering spiders or something like that
which is like the most venomous spider
in the world
and he goes no and i was like he goes
they all sold out i'm like
you're selling brazilian wandering
spiders
in rancho cucamonga but god love but god
love the people that want to own
uh the most venomous spider in the world
that's a fun crew so i walked in there i
like to
peek into these worlds but i don't know
that i can i don't want to be in it
i just want to peer into it you know
so me and ben walked in we almost got a
goliath i have the photo on my phone of
the spider we almost bought if you go
get my phone
yeah we could put it up i have despite
the picture of the spider and uh
we almost bought this spider and the guy
tells us he goes listen i gotta be
honest because before you take this
thing home
i want to run through some housekeeping
with you i said okay
he goes it's gonna flick microscopic
hairs at you which we know this is the
spider's defense mechanism
and he goes you're going to get in your
throat and your eyes
and he goes he goes they just got in my
eyes and throat and i said how long did
that last he goes nine days
i said nine days nine days so it just
flicks the microscopic hairs you get in
your throat your eyes it could be a real
problem
he also said the fangs are like three
quarter of an inch
they will pierce bone
this is very odd when you're about to
buy something for 175
and the thing that got me was he goes
you feed him one madagascar hissing
cockroach
a week even the the hairs and the bone
piercing
were getting to me but they weren't it
was when he said
you gotta get cockroaches the big
hissing concrete
and the idea of just driving around in
my car with hissing cockroaches
in the back you've just made one
purchase and become another type of
person
like you've just spent 175 dollars
and literally become a totally different
human being
than the one you were before where
people start getting worried about you
like friends of mine would be worried
about me i'd be like oh yeah that's the
hissing cockroaches for the spider
they'd be like
hey man are you all right i thought
things were kind of good
i'm like no no things are great i'm just
in the spiders that can kill me
now that's what i like i like having a
tank full of spiders that could
kill me the goliath cannot kill you it's
venom is
you know potent to a degree but it's not
like a brazilian wandering spider or a
black widow
right brown widow uh we're trying to
figure out
speaking this but we thought we saw
brown recluse the other night in the
yard but then
we went on google and they're like they
don't exist in southern california
i was reading some forum and one guy is
my favorite thing my favorite thing is
just watching anonymous fights sometimes
and a doctor an entomologist you know a
specialist or whatever
you know or an invertebrate zoologist
whatever study spiders
the the guy goes hey man uh there are no
sp there's no brown recluses in
southern california there's a challenge
because there's just no brown recluses
and then uh one guy just right under
right under it goes hey
hey [ __ ] you i was bitten woodland hills
that just made me laugh so hard
hey [ __ ] you so we we don't know if
there are actually brown
recluses here or not i'm sure people
will will
now chime in and be like no i was big by
but people are also idiots and have no
idea like i'm sure people go in and go
is this a broad recluse bite and the
doctor goes that's a gunshot wound
you were shot like oh